Should I update the supplements that you recommended after my cheek swab testing to include the one in the protocols that you created for my cancer type on small cell lung cancer?
Where there are several protocols and many extra supplements in the member site under protocols.
No, don't do that.
So I have those protocols in there just for people to look at.
I've created all those protocols, but it's just for informational sake.
And if you really want to look at and spray about like, is there, what would be the next thing to add?
Just like that other question about adding modified citrospector or adding this or adding that.
You can look at those protocols. Does it mean that you should do them? No.
Does it mean that you can? Yes, but you don't have to.
So, but if you look at that and you go, I really, I was thinking about this one.
And let me then pray about it. If you want to add one thing or something else, then that by all means you're welcome to do so, but you're not obligated to do so.
So really, you're not obligated to do anything, but you're the recommendations that you just follow when I gave you on your cheek swarm test.